how are you doing james good how are you
good how are you i'm so good obviously a
lot of times there aren't shows where
you get to write and direct and have it
be your full vision but this one even
more so because you know it was such a
contained thing what was putting this
show together and actually doing it
during this crazy couple of years that
we've had for you
well it was really truly the most
the most creatively fulfilling process
i've ever had because it came from a
purely creative place i was miserable in
lockdown i was miserable and uh i uh and
i just wrote the show mostly to soothe
myself mostly to
distract myself from all of the things i
was feeling anxiety about or the things
i was depressed about so it came from
this purely creative place for me
um and and then fortunately was able to
become a television show but it was
it was you know my days during that time
were depressing and the highlight of my
day every day was writing for however
many hours and discovering the show
which i did i wrote the show i wrote
eight episodes in eight weeks uh and
gave myself the job of writing one x a
week is which is what i did that is so
crazy and the cool thing just from
talking to the people i've interviewed
so far
there's such a good energy between
everyone where it's like it felt like
such family um and putting this all
together it definitely comes across when
you watch it so
part of that i think is in the dance
opening titles can you tell me a little
bit about how that came about well that
was just i mean i just wrote it into the
script it was always there you know the
concept was was clear early on the song
was chosen it was in the script um and
the idea that it would be this
incredibly eccentric dance um with
everyone looking incredibly serious that
was the idea and um
uh i hired a woman by the name of
carissa barton who was the choreographer
and i ended up finding out that she was
married to my friend alan tudyk which
was crazy
um you probably know yeah and
alan uh and al and when we when she was
initially sending me different dance
moves it was always alan doing it like
in their living room you know what i
mean so i have all of i have alan doing
the entire peacemaker dance for the
whole thing i mean it's good and not so
much that looks good
and uh
that's how i that's how it came to be
um and i think that you see alan he's
been tweeting a lot about the show i
think it's because his you know
supporting his wife and also because
he's he's a part of it he's a part of
the creation of this show yeah i can't
wait for everyone to see it so what was
it about this character or john's
performance in suicide squad that made
you say okay i want to do a whole like
basically like a seven eight hour movie
about this character
well i think it was it was a number of
things it was that i wanted to work with
john again and i also saw an opportunity
to work with with steve and jen um and
uh and i thought it was you know we saw
in the suicide squad we saw the other
characters arcs pretty well we we
learned where ratcatcher was from where
bloodsport was from where polkadot man
was from they all had changes their
lives that they went through on their
journey and peacemaker we didn't learn
much about him and i felt like
there were so many things that john and
i talked about on set about how he felt
isolated from everyone else about how
socially awkward he was about how he
brags about himself and talks about how
great he is because he feels like he
can't connect with anybody else through
any way other than dominating them
well i'm really excited for everybody to
see it and i love the fact that it was
something that helped you get through a
hard time because you can see that kind
of balance of dark and light in the show
so yeah i'm happy for everybody to see
it and i'm so excited for you so good to
see you as always
yeah
not too distant future i know